- I heard that Hilary Duff,
did she host like, an
entertainment play date?
Like, what happened with your kids?
What happened?
- Well Hilary is a close friend
and she has a daughter who is
six weeks younger than Gus.
And she's like supermom.
She has three kids
but she decided to start
hosting this music class
at her house.
And there's lots of other
new moms in our group,
Megan Trainer and Ashley Tisdale.
So it kind of became
like, a bit of a thing
but there's lots of other
people that have lots
of other jobs in this
class, but it's so much fun.
Like I think in this time
of COVID and, you know,
having a kid in the midst of a pandemic
like, finding community to lean on
and be able to like, have your kids sort
of start to grow up
together, but also like....
- And have those pods
where your kids can play
with other kids.
- For sure, it's so essential.
So I'm really grateful
that Hilary has done us all
this giant favor.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Yeah.
- 'Cause it's a lot to host
something like that, yeah.
- Clean up your home.
- Especially a mom of three.
Get it Hilary Duff.
- I know.
- [Drew] She tryin' to
make us look bad, Mandy.
- She does it all, for sure.